[Musique]
la sphère archers gosses c'est le nouvel
épisode de notre saga eux les gars y'a
un truc qui cloche sur les marchés c'est
l'histoire d'un rebond spéculatif de
gestion de patrimoine sur lequel les
banques ont misé archers gosses un fonds
d'investissement d'environ 10 milliards
de dollars à persuader plusieurs banques
de lui prêter trois fois plus de fonds
30 milliards pour mener à bien ses
investissements un pari risqué en gros
les banques acheter des actions et
archers gosse toucher une partie des
gains si leur valeur augmenter et devait
payer pour couvrir des pertes si les
titres chuter la chute d'une action via
comme cbs a précipité la catastrophe
les banques ont demandé à archet gosses
de couvrir des pertes mais le late show
n'en avait plus les moyens précipitant
la vente par les banques des titres
achetés pour son compte
résultat des vertes énorme 4 milliards
d'euros pour le crédit suisse 2 pour
nomura la deuxième banque
d'investissement japonaise 100 millions
d'euros pour ubs
l'afer a également fait plonger les
indices boursiers
les autorités boursières américaines
japonaises et suisses tentent déjà de
comprendre comment de tels risques ont
pu être pris surtout quand on sait que
bill wingles patron d'archers gosses
avaient été condamnés pour délit
d'initié en 2012
[Musique]